this episode is brought to you by Roka
makers of the world's most versatile
eyewear I am incredibly impressed with
Roka actually the quality is outstanding
and a lot of my friends who are Elite
athletes also wear them that's how I was
introduced to them I like to stay active
a lot of long term listeners will know
this and my eyewear has to be up to the
task brands that make everyday eyewear
sunglasses and glasses don't generally
build them for people who are really on
the move a lot so you have to wear
clunky shades on a run deal with glasses
that slip off your face or buy some kind
of sport specific frames Roka has fixed
all of that by packing the same features
used in eyewear for Olympic gold
medalists and world champions into
stylish everyday sunglasses eyeglasses
and reading glasses so you get more with
less it's an elegant solution with Roka
one pair does it all you can go from
work to a workout to dinner with friends
without ever needing to switch glasses I
never have to interrupt a hike for
instance to take my sunglasses is often
wipe my nose or frames because roca's no
slip feature keeps my shades right where
they started if you wear prescription
glasses which I will probably end up
wearing pretty soon as you get older you
know these things happen you can finally
ditch the contacts and have no slip
fashionable frames that keep up with you
and your active lifestyle personally
I've been using their Rory blue light
glasses after Sunset and I can feel the
Improvement in My Sleep Quality I'm
falling asleep faster during the day
I've been loving the Falcon this is
roca's ultra lightweight titanium
aviators been wearing those say when I
go out on nice sunny days in Austin for
long walks I also enjoy supporting Roca
speaking of Austin as Hometown Heroes is
they are based in my backyard right here
in Austin Texas roca's Ultra lightweight
no slip fit and advanced lens Coatings
combined with their exceptional style I
actually have many other styles I just
mentioned too also make these a favorite
for a lot of my friends you may have
heard about about them from Andrew
huberman and many others there are a lot
of people wearing these things the
quality as I mentioned before is really
outstanding they are very very durable
and with more than 19
000 five-star reviews can't wait until
they get to twenty thousand that'll be a
celebration I bet but with more than 19
000 five-star reviews Roka has created a
solution that active people love plus
they hand build their glasses sunglasses
and reading glasses all in the USA check
out my favorite frames and get 20 off of
your first order using Code Tim 20
that's Tim two zero at roca.com that's
code tim20 at roca.com roka.com
thank you
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus with 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands starts
shaking so now I answer your personal
questions
[Music]
foreign
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it's my job
to interview and attempt to deconstruct
world-class performers from all
different domains whether it's military
chess art music and in this case
entrepreneurship and Technology my guest
today is Dustin Moskowitz you can find
him on Twitter at Moscow V so
m-o-s-k-o-v Dustin is co-founder and CEO
at Asana a leading Work Management
platform for teams asana's mission is to
help Humanity Thrive by enabling all
teams to work together effortlessly
prior to Asana he co-founded Facebook
and was a key leader within the
technical Staff first in the position of
CTO and then later as VP of engineering
Dustin attended Harvard University as an
economics major for two years before
moving to Palo Alto California to work
full-time at Facebook and there is a lot
more to his bio we do explore a lot in
this conversation but before I get to
the that you can find Asana at
asana.comasana.com and as mentioned
before you can find Dustin on Twitter at
Moscow
v-m-o-s-k-o-v and I should just mention
a few of the things we touch upon we
dive into energy management we talk
about coaching and really performing for
endurance we talk about no meeting
Wednesdays as part of energy management
understanding the real risks of AI the
real perhaps existential risks of AI and
its counterpart which is embracing the
benefits the frictionless work that
might be possible with AI current
Integrations what that looks like the
value of holding stories Loosely how to
communicate and resolve conflict more
effectively the 15 commitments of
conscious leadership we get into a lot
in this conversation we also talk about
self-care physical and otherwise we
touch upon pretty much everything asset
of work life balance and work life
performance in addition to all of that
we've added a number of resources to the
show notes which you can find at
tim.blog podcast including Dustin's book
recommendations and time budget template
this is a spreadsheet that you can use
yourself and I don't believe he has
shared these things publicly before so
there's a lot to dig into and without
further ado please enjoy a wide-ranging
conversation with none other than Dustin
Moskowitz
nice to see you and nice to reconnect
thanks for making the time yeah
absolutely great to be here Tim I would
like to begin with a device in common
and it's a manipulation tool it's
actually sitting right next to me I have
this anywhere I might happen to be and
for those who can't see it it looks
almost like I would say an S made of
hard plastic it's about let's just call
it two and a half three feet long with
all sorts of knobs and
and odd shaped things sticking out of it
what is it that I'm holding up and I
have you to thank for introducing me to
it so let's let's explain to folks what
we're talking about yeah of course so
this is the the back buddy it's a
massage tool I have my own right here as
well and similarly wherever I go I have
them in you know home in the gym I
travel with a sort of collapsible
version uh so this is something that I
first found maybe 10 years ago I think
literally just by trying to look at the
highest rated Amazon products and I was
like oh wow this thing has like I think
at the time like 45
000 ratings and it was near a five star
rating I thought this must be great and
so I got one and it's been almost a love
affair ever since
you know really gotten to just kind of
know it better and better over time and
you know even I think last night I found
like a new kind of angle that really got
into you know under my shoulder blade in
just the right way and really
appreciated it there's other products
like this like the theracane I've tried
them I'm sure some of them are are
almost as good but this is the one I
really love they're also they're really
cheap I think they're about thirty
dollars and they're completely
indestructible I still have the first
one I bought 10 years ago in addition to
probably nine honors so it's my favorite
among many of these kind of tools I've
been very impressed just uh last little
bit on the on the back buddy using these
two very close together knobs for the
back of the neck sort of the neck
extensors I've been shocked how
effective it is for not just relaxing my
neck for extension but even rotation
spending 30 seconds on it is surprising
and for 30 off use backbody.com no
there's no affiliation or anything with
the company but it is a good tool now
before we start recording I was
mentioning some lower back pain that I'm
contending with and you had responded
that I think you've written an article
on addressing back pain and you
mentioned specifically Lidocaine patches
and this happens to be the second time
Lidocaine patches have come up in the
last 24 hours for the first time in my
life so would you mind expanding on that
just a little bit yeah so you know I
spent a lot of my 20s doing the classic
throw out your back thing you know in
obnocious ways like one time I did it
while sneezing and I had been like tying
my shoes so I had like my legs crossed
and it's very frustrating you throw out
your back and you're sort of laid up for
three or four days so it definitely went
deep on just trying to get advice on on
what to do and that can lead you in a
lot of directions including to
psychological mechanisms like the the Dr
Sarno stuff and also I just became very
acutely aware of it so I could sort of
feel my back feels like a little tweaked
right now that's usually what it feels
like you know a couple days before this
injury happens this acute thing and so I
learned that when that happens I need to
address it I either need to relax or I
need to do yoga or something like that
and eventually I found the these
Lidocaine patches first I bought the
Biofreeze ones which are Menthol based
they work great too they're basically
equivalent but they have a smell and my
wife really just likes it the lidocaine
ones have the same impact but they don't
have a smell so I really like those and
basically if you feel this tweak or just
now I use them all the time like after a
workout just slap it on my lower back
wear it for six or seven hours and
usually that just helps things really
release even if I'm still you know
sitting up during that six or seven
hours not doing anything special and
usually I'll have like a pretty good
back crack at the end of that or
something like that I also love to put
them kind of between my shoulder blades
again for the for the neck tension and
it just feels like this incredible hack
it's totally topical so it doesn't mess
with your head or make you you know
drowsy or anything like that and yeah I
just really love them I buy them
probably you know 20 a month or
something like that
so I want to explain also for folks who
may be listening why most likely we are
not sharing video maybe we'll share
video of me and some animal Avatar is of
your choosing but the reason I bring
this up is
in prep your team sent me a fascinating
document that I almost certainly am
going to try to emulate because I have
been in the process of hiring recently
and this is a guide this is a guide to
you it's like a user's guide for Dustin
and I just want to read a few of the I
suppose line items on the table of
contents briefly if you don't mind
how I view success how I communicate as
an example as a subcategory under that
writing is thinking meetings one-on-ones
group meetings scheduling Etc
personality and we might come back to
this Enneagram type 5 introversion
motivation management style hands-off
Candor underneath that miscellaneous
what gains and loses my trust revisiting
past decisions holding stories lightly
and then things Dustin hates now on the
it almost looks like a mood board which
I really appreciate on the on the page
of things destinate
is included being videotaped so could
you please give some context on when you
first created this document and for what
purpose you created this document
I think there was a sort of phase where
a lot of people were doing this and
Publishing them online and it sort of
coincided with the real Catalyst for me
was a book I can't remember the title I
think it's the making of a manager but
it's by Julie Zoo who's an old colleague
from Facebook at the time and she was
one of the design leads there a great
just sort of tactical book on how to be
a manager and it includes Julie's you
know sort of guide to Julie and in the
book it's sort of framed as this is for
your immediate reports and I originally
wrote the stock for them just for my
team they said hey this is great we'd
really love for the whole company to
actually be exposed to this and so now
it's included onboarding I don't really
know how many asanas actually go through
the whole thing and onboarding but I
tried to make it kind of fun and
interesting to read so hopefully some of
them would and part of the reason we did
that is because yeah I have some quirks
I'm an introvert and a CEO role and I
care a lot about managing my energy and
kind of what I think of as this this
extraversion budget it's almost like a
you know video game energy bar for me
you've had that dreams down and so
especially on a bender who's the the
head of people here at Asana just really
encouraged me hey just a lot easier for
everyone to manage your budget if they
understand how it works and so the more
people know about you the better and so
I put it out there and then the things I
hate lists I originally also sort of
created that that's a screenshot of
USANA board and originally created that
just for fun with my team a few of them
also have one and you know they were
also just like this is a great insight
into your personality so you should
include it and in the actual Asana board
you can click in I've got like some
snarky comments about each of the things
yeah just for fun at the bottom there
but it does include some things that
happen to be energy trains as well and
you know video tapings in there let me
if you don't mind drill into just a few
of these that I'm very fascinated by
that I am going to highlight for myself
just in terms of revisiting systems in
my own company under management style
you have coach for endurance would you
mind explaining what that means what
that item describes or covers you know
generally I think a lot of what I've
learned as a leader over time is just
how much of a marathon the work really
is and I think that a lot of culture and
tech industry encourages you to Sprint
just as much as possible and really
focuses on short-term productivity
measures and the consequence of that is
people burn out and so you know
definitely something we experienced at
Facebook and I seen it Asana as well
from time to time is when people leave
the company they're not necessarily
going somewhere else they're kind of
retiring or they're taking along
sabbatical they've sort of decided in
order to have a good break I actually
have to quit entirely you know I can't
just do a two or three week break and
come back back and it'll be too
stressful to even have the mental
overhead of what's waiting for me and so
you know when we're setting out to do
Asana we knew it was a big project you
know it's Enterprise collaboration
software takes a really long time to
build a business around not only a new
product but in our case a new category
and so we knew it wouldn't be a three or
four year thing and then when I flipped
the company or something like that and
be in it for a long time now it's been
13 or 14 years and I still have you know
really long runway in front of me and so
a lot of my mentality is just I've got
to be able to to keep going for as long
as possible and not burn out and I want
that for as much as my team as possible
because I really heavily value
institutional knowledge and the strength
you get from having high trust
relationships and so I really try and
Coach my team around that and I
encourage them to do that with their
leads and so on throughout the
organization one of my favorite phrases
is like don't let the long breaks get in
the way of the small breaks so sometimes
people are like oh like a year from now
I'm going to take a sabbatical and kind
of get in this mentality of I'm just
going to work really hard for the next
year it's like no you should still take
like a three-day weekend maybe a you
know a week vacation or so before that
and just like breaks during your day as
well and take your your nights and your
weekends and all of that is important so
it's almost like a fractal of balance
between rest and work and I think you
have to actually coach people to do that
they don't necessarily do it naturally
yeah that's actually been one of the
biggest challenges for me personally is
that I tend to hire very hungry
go-getters and sometimes
even despite my encouraging to embrace
self-care various types they burn the
candle at both ends and burn out they
burn themselves out and I've experienced
that personally but it's easy to I
suppose take for granted that people
will automatically do that which is in
my experience not always the case if you
get someone who's really a hard driver
on the topic of energy budgeting or
thinking about energy management you've
listed a lot of lessons over the years
and there's a lot on
wavelength.asana.com that I'd encourage
people to check out what I wanted to ask
you about is not letting decisions
linger for too long which can be energy
training so let me just read something
so that you don't have to feel like
you're on the spot at a congressional
hearing or something and here's a an
excerpt from one of those posts and
here's what it says I've learned a lot
over the years but here are a few key
learnings that I employ regularly in no
specific order and I may come back to a
few of these so I'll just read the five
number one not delegating enough is bad
for me and bad for people who could be
getting more autonomy and learning more
skills number two acknowledging that
everyone else is a partner in what
you're trying to do and not an enemy
three recognizing that you agree with
people more than you think you do where
you disagree is probably a difference of
input assumptions and not a real
conflict I'll certainly I think come
back to that one but the one I want to
ask about is four avoiding Paradox of
choice and making decisions even if
you're unsure of what strictly is the
best one at that very moment letting a
decision linger for too long is energy
draining don't let perfect be the enemy
of good and then the last one is making
sure there are regular checkpoints for
reflection and there's time to think at
a high level and not just be tactical
all the time that's extremely important
so would you mind expanding if you can
on what that ends up looking like
in terms of
avoiding Paradox of choice and making
decisions perhaps more quickly because
that is something I think I'm pretty
good at you know better than the average
bear maybe but I still have a lot of
room for improvement and my team is so
small that the more open Loops we have
the more exhausting it is for everyone
especially me so I'd love to hear you
say more about that
yeah and you know some of this is
aspirational like I think we get in
these long decision Loops as well
especially at work first maybe I should
explain the Paradox of choice too do you
think you're listening should be pleased
part of the Paradox of choice is just
this idea that if you have a choice
between two things the longer you
consider them both or even being exposed
to the second choice kind of makes you
devalue either outcome if you choose
path a you're always thinking about what
could have been with path B and vice
versa and there's some really
interesting psychological research
people have done sort of proving this in
controlled settings and so you kind of
don't want to indulge that mindset if
you can avoid it and I think the easiest
way to do that is to just pick your
battles so at my level that involves
often you know maybe just saying I don't
care I don't have a preference certainly
in my personal life I try and do that as
often as possible you know my wife has
always showing me art for the house or
something and it's just like if I don't
have a strong opinion I don't express
any opinion at all which it's worse for
her often she'd want me to but you know
I prefer not to kind of like bind my
preference if I don't have to and the
sort of other flip side of this is often
the choices that are hardest not at the
least in exactly this way where the
outcomes are going to be really similar
it turns out you didn't have a strong
opinion and so you shouldn't spend too
much energy on that so pick your battles
is sort of the the first way of going
about it and then the second is delegate
where possible and so you know it
doesn't have to be my choice in the
first place and it's good to empower
people you have to be a little careful
though because if it's one of these the
outcomes are similar you have to coach
that person too because they might end
up locked in the same sort of trap of
thinking about it too long and getting
drained and things like that and then
the third is you know being really clear
about your goals we try and start every
meeting with not only what are the goals
of the project we're talking about but
what are the goals of this meeting what
decisions are we trying to make and
being as clear as possible about what
those decisions are and when they need
to be made and putting deadlines on them
I have to praise I saw the best slide
I've ever seen in a meeting the other
day that was just a list of key
questions and it was like these
questions need to be answered by August
15th these by September 1st used by
September 15th and they had
recommendations on the first set and I
was like great let's just answer the
first six right now in this meeting we
did we got through some of the September
first ones as well and if every meeting
could have that slide I think we'd be in
really good shape I guess that strikes
me as sort of a
a really helpful proxy for what are the
goals of this meeting if people somehow
have difficulty Translating that because
it seems to abstract than just asking
what are the key questions we have to
answer in this meeting sort of seems to
perhaps get to a lot of the same ground
if we come back to delegating for a
moment and this is going to be looking
in the rear view mirror probably it
could be current day but I'm wondering
since this is also a growth area for me
before instead of taking something that
could be viewed as a problem and trying
to paint it as more of an opportunity
this is an area where I feel like I can
still improve a lot were there any
particular examples anything any any
concrete examples you'd give of things
that you found hard to delegate at any
point that ultimately were very valuable
to delegate could be any type of example
could be a category it could be
something specific just to maybe
illustrate
overcoming that type of friction it's a
tough question I think that in some
sense it's just an evolution of at the
beginning of Asana I just owned
everything and I had to consciously
decide to delegate and often did it too
late and needed to sort of hit a
Breaking Point and need to just kind of
declare bankruptcy on something but
looking back a lot of those just ended
up being effective and good to delegate
but I used to do everything from Guiding
and presenting at almost every all hands
like all that presentation content was
me and and now I'm you know most often
in the audience or I've got like a short
bit or I'm showing up for the Q a I used
to do kind of like the the year in
review and try and read about what
happened with kind of like every goal
outcome and every project and just as
the organization scaled it just was too
much and you kind of had to do that more
at different levels of abstraction where
I'm kind of doing the very highest level
one and you know I hear these stories
about a lot of startups with like a
thousand people and they say well the
founders in every interview to make sure
this person's a fit and you know things
like that I gave up on you know long ago
you know part of it just takes I love to
make these little spreadsheet models and
I have one that's just sort of showing
me how I use my time based on what the
recurring meetings are and some things I
know are going to happen week to week or
month to month then I try and go back to
it on maybe an annual basis and that can
sort of help me see here is a big time
suck and it's sort of out of proportion
can I somehow reduce this to be a more
appropriate use of my time or give it to
somebody else and that kind of helps me
each step of the way I don't know if
there's anything in particular that felt
like a you know sort of ripping after
ripping it out of my heart or something
like that how do you create or populate
the spreadsheet it's one of those things
that in theory to me for instance sounds
so appealing yet I would worry that
because of task switching or just the
number of things floating around in my
life that the simple Act of inputting
into a spreadsheet would consume a vast
amount of time how do you fill in that
spreadsheet what does it look like in
terms of just formatting I actually made
it into a template we can share in part
of the uh amazing that'd be great yeah
it sort of starts with here are the
hours for work here are the hours for
Home here are the hours for sleep so I
got that sort of biggest pie chart and
then for work I have a tab that's like
here are my recurring meetings this is
how frequently they happen this is how
long they are in some cases I have prep
time for example we have a board meeting
quarterly it is a three and a half hour
meeting I need two hours of prep there's
also some committee meetings and so this
sort of amortizes out to something like
two hours a month or something like that
or like 30 minutes a week so it becomes
a part of the chunk and those things
don't change very often and are really
kind of the bulk of it and where the
most leverages in changing something
so you know I think that those end up
adding up to like something like 30 of
the work time and then I have another
tab that is more you know more abstract
it's like responding to things in slack
and I just sort of like swag an estimate
for how long I spend on that per week or
you know interacting with customers and
those come up on the customer's Cadence
I don't have like a sort of set Block in
my calendar for that but I look back
maybe over the past month or two and
just like estimate looking backwards how
much time I spent and then what's left I
just sort of count as this is desk time
this is focus time and try and sort of
gut check does this feel right or am I
kidding myself about something and look
for other sources of time and that led
me to add in my lunch hour and my coffee
breaks and stuff like that and you know
it's hard the first time but then every
year I'm kind of just like tweaking it
and that part you know only takes 20
minutes or so
now are you setting I'm gonna get fancy
here just so I can sound smart are you
using okrs or are you after reviewing
the spreadsheets saying you know what
for the next month or next quarter I
want to hit these percentages I guess
I'm wondering what the assessment looks
like if you have questions you're trying
to answer when you review the
spreadsheet just what that process looks
like for you
I don't think I'm quite that
quantitative about it we do have okrs at
Asana and one thing I do with the help
of my my assistant Warren is I look at
my coming month and I try and organize
it under the company objectives and so
some of the objectives are about
financial management and that includes
all my time engaging with investors and
with the finance team here some of it's
about the product some of it's about
engaging with customers and so if I do
have customer meetings that's kind of
slotting in there and I think that's a
good monthly checkpoint for am I
personally contributing to the goals
where I think I'm leveraged sometimes
the sections look too long sometimes
they look too short and can kind of
course correct from there but I try not
to have too many fixed rules other than
my sort of energy gauge and my trending
towards burnouts or not do I have the
energy to do the things I need to do and
a lot of that more is sort of day to day
and week-to-week management and again my
assistant does a big part of that and
making sure I don't get overloaded too
much
God bless your assistant yeah people
think of me as an extrovert but I am
very very introverted in terms of energy
management I also have to budget for
that but I am such a dancing bear on
stage playing extrovert that I sometimes
can commit to things that are sort of
antithetical to my actual programming
but I want to come back to a few things
so the first is just a definition of
terms for folks so okay R stands for
objectives and key results if you want
to take a look at that John Dorr has a
book about it Google also uses okrs
extensively and you can find a lot
written on that on the Paradox of choice
if people want to look more into that
Barry Schwartz wrote a book called The
Paradox of choice and there's the aspect
that you described there's also the
consideration of too many options right
considering too many options and the
decision fatigue that that can produce
or just creating an excess of decision
making and it seems to me that number
five on the list of I read earlier
making sure there are regular
checkpoints for reflection there's time
to think at a high level
requires some type of strategic or
tactical move to actually Implement
right or the small things will just
crowd out the big things so I have a few
questions around that the first is do
you still or do people at Asana still
follow no meeting Wednesday or is that
sort of Case by case and even if it's
just past tense now if you could perhaps
just explain why that existed I think
that would be helpful for folks for me I
still follow it quite religiously it is
a bit Case by case throughout the
company and that often results in people
trying to schedule meetings with me on
Wednesdays
what are you doing why aren't you doing
no meeting Wednesday and yeah it comes
from two places one maybe I think it was
2011 Paul Graham had this really famous
blog post the maker manager schedule and
it was just kind of pointing out that
meetings end up on your calendar kind of
at the behest of management and team
leads and project managers and that is
their entire day so they're just kind of
like stacking their their calendar end
to end but I see is really especially in
software really need these long Focus
blocks to get into their work they need
to kind of like load up the context and
their their short-term memory get into
flow and have a good you know 90-year
120 minute session to get useful workout
and so if you don't interfere the
natural thing that happens is kind of
your calendar gets chopped up and you
don't have any of these two hour blocks
you just have these half hour or an hour
blocks and you get a little bit of work
done and it's just overall sub-optimal
for individual productivity so new
meeting Wednesday is sort of a hack of
just we're going to synchronize
everyone's calendar so that they don't
have meeting blocks on Wednesdays a lot
of people to sauna go further they'll
add additional blocks maybe Tuesday and
Thursday morning you know try and find a
couple other maybe a half day or a third
of a day segments where they can try and
keep their calendar clear and yeah
everyone else tries to respect this as
much as they can of course things happen
customer meetings happen you're not
always in control of that but we try and
join our best so partly it's just about
having those Focus blocks and partly
it's about having you know long enough
blocks to get into some deep thinking
work and you know be able to have these
longer periods of reflection and you
know I just find even as a manager if I
have just a half hour an hour I'm going
to do something small something tactical
just so I can feel productive it's hard
to get into that deep thinking State so
that's really what it's all about
yeah totally and I want to just mention
for people who may want to look it up
again the makers schedule manager
schedule by Paul Graham who's I guess
fairness co-founder of Y combinator
people may be familiar with that that
article as well as or I should say essay
I guess as well as the top idea in your
mind are two that I have bookmarked to
revisit constantly I really appreciate
how concise and clear his thinking and
as I also want to confirm you did get
the book title right for Julie Joe I'm
not sure how she pronounces her last
name the making of a manager I think
it's Zoo well you actually I think you
speak Mandarin or something so maybe I
should yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it could be any number of things so so
Julie apologies I'm getting your name
wrong but the title is the making of a
manager and the no meeting Wednesday
brings up a question for me of weekly
architecture I find that I do very well
if I have some semblance of a weekly the
architecture so for instance we're
recording on a Friday I tend to record
podcasts if I record podcasts Monday and
Friday at 10 A.M wherever I happen to be
or roughly 3 P.M wherever I happen to be
and I found that
just reduces so much complexity it makes
communication much more smooth it makes
planning in the long term much easier in
terms of blocking out time over a month
a quarter Etc and then there are say for
instance from a team calls and
everything happened on a Tuesday and
that's all formatted in a certain way do
you have a particular weekly
architecture that you aim for or that
during periods of high productivity that
you've followed well I think that the
weekly Cadence like including no meeting
Wednesday really defines a lot a lot
falls out from that so Asana has an
office Centric hybrid policy so we're
Wednesdays since they have no meetings
you can work from home totally fluid
Fridays are also pretty fluid and you
know I'm here on a Friday but relatively
low attendance and so Monday Tuesday
Thursday is when a lot of our meetings
are going to happen including my team
meets Tuesday afternoon and you know I'd
love to say I designed that for a
particular reason but really that's when
our calendar is aligned in the right
away and then you know I mentioned I
have the kind of Tuesday Thursday
morning work blocks for getting more
stuff done and between those and
Wednesday that's sort of the me time the
IC time and then most of the rest of
Monday Tuesday Thursday will be meetings
I see as individual contributor yes you
know I think of it as you can be an IC
in your manager role as well it's like
when you're not in meetings you're
producing things and coaching people and
then Friday partially because I really
prefer in-person meetings ends up being
pretty light as well even though I'm
here just like a couple meetings and a
lot of work block time as well why do
you prefer in-person meetings well it's
partially for the same reason I don't
like being video recorded I find that
part of my attention is lost in a video
call and it depends a lot on the quality
of the connection and the audio and the
video I don't know what your experience
is like but you're quite pixelated for
me right now and so it's like a little
harder to pick up on your your body
language your emotional
and I just find after a video call I'm
so drained and if it's a team meeting I
find the control flow very difficult
it's very difficult for people to
interrupt or interject they literally
raise their hand to sort of put
themselves in the queue I just find it a
lot less efficient than being in a room
and having the more sort of natural
Cadence of dialogue and again the AV
issues pop up in the team meetings too
and it's it's a disaster every time I
don't know three years into the pandemic
and all the same problems from 2020 are
still here but they are and and I just
like I can't look past it to feeling
like it's good enough yeah you know I
didn't really consider the energetic
cost of what you're describing but it's
true there is something as much as we
try or hope that it will be natural that
is unnatural about looking at the Brady
Bunch on a screen and trying to
coordinate body language and cues
there's an energetic cost to that I want
to come back to number three in the list
that I mentioned and it's going to be a
jumping off point so recognize that you
agree with people more than you think
you do where you disagree is probably a
difference of input assumptions and not
a real conflict I think this may tie
into a question about conscious
leadership which I would love to discuss
and in your book recommendation
list that you sent me I do want to talk
about the top recommendation at some
point But at the there are two books
that begin the list we'll leave the
first as a cliffhanger for now so top
recommendation is the beginning of
infinity by David Deutsch who I had on
the podcast with Naval ravacon and I do
want to ask you about that because that
is not an easy book to read necessarily
very interesting and then right below
that is leadership and strategy and the
first book is the 15 commitments to
conscious leadership
how did you get introduced to conscious
leadership or this book
so I think it was
you know almost 12 or 14 years ago I
went to an event Southern California I
can't remember where and it had some
great people there including Diana
Chapman and actually Jack cornfield who
you had on the the show last week and it
was kind of my my first exposure to some
of those people it was a pretty small
group I think there were 15 people in
the group and so we got to kind of know
them and ended up deciding to work with
Diana as a personal coach and that led
to more and more I think this was even
before the book was published
and then you know as we were starting
Asana it became just kind of the
framework that we wanted everyone to
learn I think 15 commitments is really
great I also think it's very similar to
other Frameworks but it's nice to have a
similar set of language and this idea of
holding stories lightly and
understanding that the other perspective
more it also relates to something Jack
brought up with with Byron Katie so she
loves to preface any thought with I have
a story that these are all kind of
related ideas but having the 15
commitments is something very concrete
and language like being above the line
below the line it's really helpful for
everyone in the company to know what
those terms mean so that you can
shorthand them and so now you'll go into
a meeting and somebody will be in a bad
mood and frustrated about a decision
we're making and they'll just voice out
loud I'm below the line about this I'm
expressing some frustration but that
doesn't mean stop what you're doing or
I'm like throwing my my body on the
tracks it just means that that's where
I'm at right now I'd love to shift maybe
you can help me shift but just be aware
and so that's very useful and it comes
up all the time in my one-on-ones with
how I coach people in fact I start all
my one-on-ones just with how are you
feeling because often it will emerge
well they're feeling below the line or
there's something going on in their life
and that's going to affect our
conversation and I'd rather know about
it than not
foreign
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront there is a lot happening in
the U.S and Global economies right now a
lot that's an understatement are we in a
recession is it a bear Market what's
going to happen with inflation so many
questions so few answers I can't tell
the future nobody can but I can tell you
about a great place to earn more on your
savings and that's wealthfront
wealthfront is an app that helps you
save and invest your money right now you
can earn 4.8 apy that's the annual
percentage yield with the wealthfront
cash account that's more than 11 times
more interest than if you left your
money in a savings account at the
average Bank according to fdic.gov so
why wait earn 4.8 percent on your cash
today plus it's up to five million
dollars in FDIC insurance through
partner Banks and when you open an
account today you'll get an extra 50
bonus with a deposit of 500 or more
there are already nearly half a million
people using wealthfront to save more
earn more and build long-term wealth so
why wait visit wealthfront.com Tim to
get started that's wealthfront.com Tim
this was a paid endorsement by
wealthfront
got it
how have you worked with Diana who's
great spent a decent amount not as much
as you have but a decent amount of time
with her she is one of a kind and very
very good at what she does how have you
worked with her if you're open to
discussing it to whatever extent
one-on-one what does the format look
like or what were you hoping to
accomplish in working with her were you
working with her mostly because you were
basically test driving language and
shared Concepts that you hope to put
into Asana was it mostly individual in
the beginning and to add a personal
interest
yeah it's interesting it's changed over
time I don't have a one-on-one coaching
relationship with her at the moment but
a lot of it you know when I first
started I was a total novice on the
commitments and I had a lot of stories I
was I was holding tightly and they were
impacting my energy because I believed
them and she really helped me a lot with
that part of the reason I don't work
with her anymore is like I kind of know
what she's going to say every time and
so I'll do the back and forth on my own
are you open to and if not that's okay
and it could be a hypothetical but
sharing a story that you held tightly
sure and uh I think that would be be
useful yeah I mean I think the one that
has been most difficult for me and I
think is maybe Universal for
entrepreneurs in general is just this
sense of huge responsibility to keep
going and endure and persevere and do
well by your employees and this sort of
thing and it's very easy to feel like
you're trapped and that there's no other
possibility you're kind of just you know
Sisyphus as a leader and I don't want to
scare my place like I'm not like
thinking about leaving right now but I
think going through the coaching of this
really helped because she would just
constantly deny me on anything that I
really believed like it would be
terrible if Asana had a different CEO
and it's like well how's the opposite of
that story true maybe a new CEO would
you know bring in fresh perspective and
like they'd have more energy and like
you know things like this or be terrible
if Asana shut down and all of our
employees wasted all this time and part
of their career doing it and she'd say
well how's the opposite of that story
true what about the experiences they got
to building Asana what about the value
your customers got while Asana was alive
and obviously I'm still there so it's
not like this coaching led me to think I
should leave us on or shut it down but
it helped me understand that I was
choosing to be there and every day is in
some sense a new decision I can't just
walk away tomorrow like that has other
kinds of consequences that I choose not
to accept but in the longer Arc of time
I have agency here the Assad employees
have agency or customers have agency and
it's much more productive for me to
engage with the problems from above the
line rather than from this place of fear
and scarcity and anxiety and you know
there's time and place for that you also
need to feel all feelings and the
commencement framework but it's bad if
it's just like always a Paul on every
hour of every day and every decision and
you want to not grip around those things
and so it's useful sometimes to indulge
and how is the story not true and you
know with Diana she'll go all the way to
fear of death like you know imagine your
own funeral and like whatever your
deepest anxiety is and just try and
loosen your grip on that
and for people who want maybe a name for
the technique there's more to it and
Diana has her own flavor and approach
but the turnarounds that are often
associated with Byron Katie people can
find the work online and worksheets that
are really helpful for this if you
aren't able to work with someone like
Diana the 15 commitments is also an
excellent book and an excellent book not
just for companies it's a great book if
you want to improve your communication
with your significant other which is
actually how I used a whole large
portion of that book with significant
others I just want to add to the other
thing it's a lot like is cognitive
behavioral therapy so you know if you
want to take a more Western approach I
think it gets at the same ends with very
similar methods yeah totally one
particular aspect of what Diana Chapman
and Jim Detmer have been on the podcast
Embrace that I have
always well this is a story it's a part
of this whole training is like helps you
to identify those stories but my story
is that I have long struggled with
having incredibly uncomfortable clearing
conversations when there is a conflict
or you feel some resentment or whatever
it might be and I think historically
there's been a lot of fear for me around
the consequences of trying to have an
open conversation about these things
so my question is how do you handle that
if you implement it at Asana those types
of clearing conversations or broadly
speaking if this is easier just
disagreements tension between or among
employees and so on yeah it's a big
company so I don't think it happens the
same way everywhere but would I try and
Coach people to do and what I experience
with my media team is that we do try and
get into this mode you know it's a
little bit conscious leadership it's a
little bit non-violent communication but
very speaking on arguably reflecting
back what the other person said to make
sure that they feel understood I've
definitely over the years my biggest
takeaway with conflict is people want to
feel heard more than they want the
decision change a lot of it is just you
got you got to make the space for that
and if you're going to do some difficult
change management you just gotta accept
that there's going to be some of that
and it's important to do do it at the
right times can't have everyone get
involved before the decision is made but
the people who who especially need to be
bought in and need to help you to change
management after they kind of need to be
heard before it's finalized and then
even after it's communicated you know
you're gonna have to really listen to
people on why they're disappointed or
unhappy and reflect that back to them
not just he he literal sounding board
but you know actually be engaged in an
empathetic conversation I think that
goes the longest way and sometimes
people will use you know conscious
leadership has a literal clearing script
the facts are when this happened I
generated this story or I had these
feelings and this is meant to explicitly
get away from language like you did this
and that made me feel angry you know the
whole idea with conscious leadership is
you're responsible for your own feelings
and you know you're going to have a
reaction that doesn't necessarily mean
the person was trying to hurt you or
that that's really what happened often
it has to do with you know stuff from
your past or your childhood or
situations like that that you don't want
to experience again and your body is
bringing them up again and so just
trying to bring some awareness to that
bring it into the room there's two
people in the conflict and they're in
different positions of of power or
different positions with respect to the
decision being made but they each need
to play their role in a mindful way and
be as the line as they can and be
present and that's really what we're
going for the conscious leadership
scripts are outstanding you do need some
shared vocabulary to play that game with
someone so they kind of need to be
signed up for the same set of rules but
can be super effective and I wanted to
underscore non-violent communication by
Marshall Rosenberg I listen to the
audiobook which I think has a peace sign
a hand making a peace sign on it so
don't necessarily be put off the cover's
a little bizarre but the format itself
that plus conscious leadership and some
of the scripts I'd say over the last
three years have three to four years
really changed how I approach
Communication in general and what I've
experienced personally I'll try to keep
this short but is having some type of
structured way of thinking about how are
you are going to open a conversation
also gives you
chance and maybe a catalyst to
de-escalate whatever emotion happens to
be running really hot or really hard and
the simple Act of saying something
inarguable starting with what I hear you
saying is ABC did I get that right is
there more and then having when X
happened as a video camera would record
it right when you wrote this sentence in
this email I felt this the story I have
around that is this
would you be willing to agree to this
having a request at the end it's
remarkable what you can get accomplished
especially if you have a history of
being a bit of a bull in a china shop
like I do the transformation is quite
something sometimes when you're talking
about this you get the sense of like
everyone kind of has to be a Zen Monk
and like totally in control of their
emotions I also just want to really
emphasize you know one of the
commitments is feel your feelings and
sometimes that means like purposely
going to those lines like as far as you
can getting on the drama triangle making
it playful and just like Hamming it up
really making that person like the
biggest scariest villain monster you can
I really think that's an important part
of it and everyone's gonna have like a
different way of doing it but you know I
think if you try and you've talked about
struggling with anger management in the
past I think I do that too if you try
and solve that by withholding and
containing all that anger you end up
lower back pain and
yeah it still comes out anyway and it
comes out in the wrong you know for a
totally different situation that's
unrelated to the thing you're really
angry about and so it's really important
to like go through that and part of the
way I do that is maybe I'll just write
it all out you know I'll have like a
Google doc or a sauna task and just kind
of go crazy just you know stream of
Consciousness you know sometimes Move
Your Body Hit things you know I really
want to put that in there too is an
important part of doing this well and
then once you've process your feelings
and like move them through your body
then you can have that about the line
conversation yeah I appreciate you
saying that's a good reminder for me
also that you know swinging from one
extreme to the other and neglecting to
express that stuff might very well
contribute to my mysterious lower back
pain so I promised listeners that I
wouldn't leave them hanging with the
Cliffhanger on David Deutsch so would
you mind explaining why that book
features so prominently in your book
recommendations and for people who want
the title it's the beginning of infinity
subtitle explanations that transform the
world it's been a while since I've gone
through it myself but I've read it
probably three times first of all I find
it just really fascinating and enjoyable
before reading that book for a long time
I said that girl was my favorite book
but I had never finished it because it's
tough it's tough it's tough yeah but
it's really entertaining and some of the
ways that it's entertaining I think also
feature in beginning of infinity like he
has these you know sections in between
the chapters that are more narrative and
fun without nearly as much math there's
a little bit but it's not like GB we
have you know you have to have advanced
math degree to get through it but the
big lesson from it is this idea that
problems are soluble we build on
knowledge and no matter how immense a
problem seems as long as it is possible
to solve within the laws of natural
physics it generally can be solved and
over time you know we've had all these
crisis moments in humanity where it's
felt like that's not true there was a
resource running out there was an
irreconcilable conflict and people just
couldn't see the weight of the future
and what happens is the pressure builds
up and you get more and more attention
on solving this problem and lo and
behold it gets solved and sometimes the
reason it's so scary is is a form of you
know status quo bias so people think
everything will be exactly like it is
now except we won't have this important
resource I think there's a story about a
particular element that's needed that
was needed for TVs in the 50s you know
what I'm talking about
I don't know I don't know that example
the price of oil and oil supply would be
another example yeah totally so like you
know for a long time with energy people
thought well we'd run out of oil at some
point and that would that would be the
end of energy and then of course we we
have all these alternative sources now
that can supplant it and you know these
are also solutions to to CO2 problems
the TV one is nice just because there
was a while people didn't think you
would be able to have the sort of
cathode ray tube TVs anymore because of
something was going to go away and then
now we have liquid Crystal displays that
don't involve the element at all and so
this is an example of sasco bias because
people couldn't imagine a different way
to accomplish the goal of getting a
crisp video image you know to people in
a broadcast format and so he just goes
through a bunch of examples like that
and gives you this sense of like you
know how powerful Humanity really is and
what the power of compounding knowledge
really is all right let's uh I'll leave
people to explore that book and
certainly if they want an overview they
can listen to the the podcast with David
Deutsch and myself and Naval ravacon I
let Naval do the heavy lifting on that
one for a million and one reasons yeah
but I do I do feel like the premise that
problems are soluble or many problems
are soluble is a good
jumping off point to effective altruism
you're one of the largest funders of
effective altruism and I'd like to
explore this and discuss it a bit could
you begin maybe with just explaining for
folks who don't know the term what
effective altruism is and then you can
take it wherever you like and I can also
certainly help hop in I feel the need to
preface this with there's some
disagreement about what it is so I'll
tell you I'll tell you my perspective
which I think it's really it's an idea
and some people call it a movement but
it's really it brings together people
who are interested in asking the
question how do we do the most good and
that can take the form of philanthropic
donations it can take the form of how
you spend your career like maybe which
non-profit you would work for or in a
lot of cases they're part of what's
called earning to give and so they just
choose a sort of normal career with a
high-paying job with a plan to then
donate some of their earnings as
effectively as they can and so that
leads you to
you know a certain set of ideas so as a
philanthropist I think of effective
altruists as defined by cause
agnosticism so that means rather than
coming to philanthropy with what I care
about is education or what I care about
his climate you're coming with just the
point of view I'd like to do the most
good
and that leads you to different places
that sometimes look very strange because
it turns out that when you're the next
philanthropist on the margin the thing
that does the most good is often
something that's important that other
people aren't doing for whatever reason
you know it doesn't have enough
attention or it's not as sexy or it
requires really kind of going deep on
the logic of why this is important and
so you end up not doing the things that
most other people are doing and so the
overarching framework that we use for
choosing cause areas is it it has to be
important hard to do do good without
working on important things it has to be
tractable so it has to be possible to
make progress and then it should be
neglected so that you're you're doing
good because this is the good that other
people aren't doing so it's a form of
sort of comparative advantage
what would some examples be excite can
imagine if I'm acting as a stand-in for
the audience they're like well how do
you figure out what is most good or the
greatest good for the greatest number of
fill in the blank is it biased towards
and measured in human lives is it some
other metric how do you determine what
is good would you mind giving a few
examples of cause areas or specific
projects that you've ended up landing on
based on the type of vetting you're
describing and this is where I think
some of the subjectivity comes in
because I don't think there's a one
answer to what that metric is so the one
that is sort of easiest to understand is
global health and well-being so we do a
lot of work particularly in the
developing World particularly around
malaria's probably the single largest
destination for our grant money and
there it is often just measured in the
number of lives saved or the equivalent
so it's this idea of a quality adjusted
life year that kind of lets you convert
the value of helping somebody avoid
debilitating disease or you know maybe
takes years off their life or even
increases their earning power how might
you make that equivalent to helping a
child make it past their fifth year
because a malaria event Nets are helping
them avoid a fatal infection and so with
in global health and well-being that's
where you kind of have the most
similarity in the goals and can kind of
trade off the different opportunities
against each other and in a fairly clean
way though it can still get you know it
can still involve a lot of judgments so
there's a lot of debate about whether
the goal should be about mortality or
perhaps subjective happiness or perhaps
earning power which is a kind of like
proxy for economic empowerment giving
people as much choice in the world as
possible but often you're debating
things that are that are very similar
you're going to help avoid a child death
through baleria bednets or perhaps
through iodine a supplementation and
they have pretty similar well maybe
that's not a great example for avoiding
a death avoiding intestinal worms like
something that would really mess you up
so that's an easy compare second big
category is animal welfare and there we
work especially on factory farm animal
welfare because that's where a very
large amount of the animals with either
full Consciousness or a great deal of
Consciousness Live and Die in the world
I think I was reading a stat that is
something like
nine chickens are slaughtered every year
for every human on earth so it's
something close to 100 million chickens
and so if you can improve the welfare of
those animals a little bit you can
reduce quite a lot of suffering and that
gets you to a very clear subjective
point about the good because a lot of
people will say this doesn't matter at
all you should spend infinite money on
helping one human before you think at
all about these chickens or these cows
and I think that's a judgment call I
think it's fair that people have
different points of view on that but
from the perspective as a single a
funder in the space it's something that
we feel sympathetic to and then the last
category is global catastrophic risks so
these are it's been the debate about the
name recently but I think the clearest
definition is these are things that
actually cause Extinction or cause
modern civilization to be set back 2000
years something really catastrophic and
this gets debated for a lot of reasons
with the philosophical point is sort of
whether you care about the seizing of
life or if you just care about suffering
you know you could take the point of
view that it's great that the people are
here and we don't want the ones that are
live now to suffer but if kind of the
Lights Went Out for everyone else
tomorrow maybe you're fine with that or
maybe you don't care at all about the
people who haven't been born yet or
things like this I don't like to go too
far into the future Generations because
I think in practice it doesn't matter
that much I think the threats are quite
soon kind of affect the people that are
live today but there is a a set of EAS
that you know are putting a lot of the
weight on the sort of I think it's like
45 trillion theoretical future human
lives and making sure that they get to
actually experience the world and that
something doesn't stop it before we get
there and so that's where we work on
things like pandemics and biosecurity
risks as well as potential risks from
Advanced artificial intelligence
all right we're gonna dive into a couple
of follow-ups related to these and uh
the first is related to animal welfare
and suffering which I think a lot about
and I read that you are directionally
vegetarian and I would love for you to
explain what directionally vegetarian
means I always feel a little sheepish
about this because from a pure ethics
perspective I sort of feel like vegans
are right but I also you know I know a
lot of vegans and vegetarians and I see
how they struggle with some of their
eating decisions and I know what the
experience is like for me and so I just
feel better when there is a little bit
of beat in my life but I've cut way back
it probably was somebody 10 or 15 years
ago that would have some kind of beef
meal every single day or chicken meal
and you know the other many days where
there's no meat my diet and I'm very
interested in the alternative meat
products especially the ones from
impossible Foods where the foundation is
actually taking investment and basically
I'm in a place where if the alternative
is even like half as good or three
quarters is good I'd much rather have
that and it gives me the same sort of
you know satiation that real meat does
and mostly I feel limited by
availability I decided I've like pushed
for The Culinary team to just like serve
it more often and had impossible Burgers
earlier this week I was like great
definitely going to eat that one and you
know we have some home-cooked meals and
try and incorporate it there and in San
Francisco it's in in a fair amount of
restaurants but it's still pretty rare
but I definitely seek those restaurants
out and I found a few like great takeout
places and I'm just like really eager
for this future where that's in our diet
and I feel ready for it but for the
availability it's kind of how I think
about it so if we hop from some of those
cause areas to
perhaps
forward-looking perspectives is there
anything that you've been watching and
particularly interested
in funding or considering funding that
is outside of the cause areas that you
mentioned
well those are pretty sweeping buckets
they are broad yeah on the global
catastrophic threats I don't know if I'm
getting that phrasing
correct but on the pandemic side it
seems like the the effective altruism
Community was focused on pandemics on
some level even before 2020 came around
and covid how do you think about
let's just focus on that before we get
to AI because I know that AI is going to
be a whole different kettlefish on the
pandemic side
what levers do you try to pull what are
most important in terms of high leverage
or important
perhaps neglected or under exploited
underfunded and so on with respect to
pandemics how do you think about
trying to uh I suppose help with
preparedness or or other aspects
so we've been in a space since 2016 and
so in those early years it was partially
just trying to make people understand
that this was a real possibility there
really hadn't been anything since you
know I guess the the first you don't
call it the Spanish flu anymore but the
1919 pandemic and so we've sort of fall
into this complacency but we could see
that there were a lot of things like
globalization that were increasing
vulnerability for a global scale
pandemic and that it just felt like a
matter of time so partially raising
awareness now of course covid-19 is has
dramatically increased that but it
hasn't increased the preparation so it's
been really disappointing to see not
only has there not really been budget
for sort of cleaning up this pandemic
but there's very little money going into
preparation for the next one in terms of
government skill funding and so we still
feel somewhat defenseless I think people
are a lot more aware they kind of know
what some of the Playbook will be if
there's another pan endemic and I'm
really encouraged by things like a focus
on indoor air quality I think is a huge
deal what do you mean by that well like
during covid and especially if you live
through the California wildfires people
got into like the HEPA filters and
things that are sort of processing here
there's some research right now with
with far UBC this is kind of like a
ultraviolet light that can kill bacteria
and viruses in the air and the only
reason we're not deploying it everywhere
is there's there are unknown uh
long-term Health side effects
um and so I think we have some grants in
this area I know some people are funding
Research into exploring that one of the
biggest ones I think we could have is is
just if a technology like that was as
commonplace as air conditioning or water
filtration you know about water quality
is something we already have sort of
caught on to this is really important
and we have Municipal scale and also
personal scale devices that help us with
this I think doing the same with air
quality would go a long way but I think
the biggest thing that we push for is
just more surveillance of what's
circulating in the wild and there was a
point in time you know I'm sure you
remember all these debates about how
much covet actually is there is there a
bias in who's testing and are the tests
accurate and all this but there's a
shortcut uh well there's two shortcuts
one is what's called a Acero survey and
so you just kind of you try and get a
random sample of people in a local
population you do a blood test and you
just like sequence everything in their
blood and see what's there
um and if we were doing this in every
major Metro all over the world even with
relatively small samples you would catch
pandemics like covid-19 well before they
become these global scale outbreaks in
this case maybe it was being done in
China and hidden or who knows but by the
time we actually became aware of it it
was just the cat was out of the bag it
was probably like three months after the
first infection it was it was too far
gone but if you're doing this
systematically just looking for an
emerging pandemic you'd be much more
likely to catch it the easier way to do
it that I think is really interesting is
sewage samples I don't know if you've
seen any of these sites no I have not
there's a great one in the Bay Area and
they're literally just looking at a
sewage runoff and sampling for the
concentration of covid and now they've
extended it to you know monkey pox and
various types of flu and you can
literally just look at the Bay Area
cities and look at you know a two-year
Trend graph of how prevalent these
things are and so I was actually just
this morning I was reading a news
article like covet spiking in the Bay
Area and like you know these sort of
scare stories that come up from time to
time and I said hey this is my trusted
Source I'm just going to go see if it's
really spiking it's you know there's a
little increase and maybe it'll become
something more but this feels like
something that it removes all these
biases from how people test and
everything and can just be trusted is
something real all right so Dustin AI
let's uncork this monster and talk about
AI not saying monster in the pejorative
sense but this might be also a
tie-in to effective altruism because
there's been a lot of attention
and purported attention given to AI
where would you like to begin because
this is of course a topic that can go in
many different directions where would it
make sense to start
lately the the place I've been starting
is kind of getting more into the Nuance
of the positions there's been this part
of the discourse that's emerged that
that really paints everyone into two
extremes you're either entirely Pro AI
or you're sometimes people call them
doomers or yeah if you've seen this term
where I haven't even have any Yeti yeah
well it's a Yeti well it's a reference
to Elias
yeah but upon on but what is the why
well for Eliezer goodkowski who's sort
of uh okay okay yeah I get it I get it
took me a second yeah yeah uh
you know I I feel about even bringing up
the term and making it more popular but
also I love puns so much and I'm like
wow people really nailed that one but he
kind of represents the other end of the
poll of like he's the most worried about
Ai and you know is just really worried
about it as a global catastrophic risk
like we were talking about earlier or
something that could uh actually cause
human extinction or you know destroy
civilization but even with Eliezer and
even more so with me it's much more
nuanced than that he's not an actual
Luddite he's a technologist and you know
really believes in technological future
he believes in the power of AI he
started out enormously Pro Ai and then
as he got into it sort of came to
understand some serious risks that you
know felt like he needed to be addressed
and I think the risks are very serious I
don't think they're quite as likely to
occur as he does and I I have more
optimism around Humanity's resiliency
and ability to address the problem for
the conversation about beginning of
infinity and I'm also just really
enthused enthusiastic about AI at the
same time I you know I wake up every day
and I'm like this is amazing there are
so many cool things I can do oh and also
I hope it doesn't kill us
um and I'm like I'm like always kind of
like having to hold the stuff yes don't
kill us yeah exactly and so I try and
you know give this analogy of like when
you when you get into a car you expect
to go to your destination but you put on
a seat belt you follow the rules of the
road and there's a regulatory system and
Licensing system for drivers that that
helps ensure sort of mutual safety for
everyone including the pedestrians and
so I really think about AI safety like
that like we are heading towards
something really awesome but there are
some serious risks we need to address
and that requires some concerted effort
and the reason it relates to effective
altruism is especially until the last
year a lot of things have been changing
pretty much nobody was working on this
partially because they thought AI was
very far off partially because they they
didn't agree that the risk would
manifest even when we got there
what are some of the risks and I
couldn't help but imagine in my mind I
was thinking you know when I was 12 for
a very long time I wanted to be a marine
biologist and I'm thinking how much of
the people in AI are like 12 year old
boys of a pet great white shark that
knows a bunch of cool tricks but man you
got to be careful with the great white
shark but what are the risks I am
particularly excited to hear you
describe them because you are technical
I am not technical to be clear I'm not
an engineer I don't play one on the
internet but I appreciate
perspectives on AI from those people who
are able to immerse themselves in some
of the more technical aspects so what
are the risks for a lay audience you
could get into the weeds a bit we do
have technical folks listening as well
but what are the what are the risks and
how how do you assign sort of
probability
to those risks if they haven't yet come
to pass and maybe some of them are
already current
well I'll start with the one where
there's a lot more agreement so we're
talking about part of our GCR work is on
biosecurity and we talked a lot about
pandemics but we also worry about
bioweapons so somebody purposefully
engineering a pathogen and you know
there are people in the world who are
trying to do this now and they have
various resources available to them some
of them are successful governments try
and stop them in various ways and
there's been no no major bioweapons but
language models especially for even more
purpose-built AIS can change this and
create more of an offense defense
imbalance so there's been some research
recently and um Dr amade who's the CEO
of anthropic recently testified to
Congress about you know how this works
where you're basically trying to solve
any problem and use language model to
help but in this case a sort of
malicious goal if you're trying to
engineer a bioweapon in a language model
can help you not get stuck along the way
work around problems and just figure out
step by step and and you know right now
what's possible the language models
don't don't help you that much they help
you a little bit but they're not at a
power level or this is a serious threat
but the worry is in another generation
or two or three they will get to a place
where it becomes really enabling for
people to have this goal to kind of work
around these problems and figure it out
especially if they already have you know
a background in biology but even if they
don't and so you know maybe you're just
enabling a lot more people to come up
with us and usually when I have this
conversation people try and relate it to
nuclear weapons and they're like what's
the equivalent of uranium you got to
regulate that and it just turns out with
bio there is nothing like that you know
we may just be in a place where it's
more like 3D printed guns where you can
get commodity hardware and this thing's
helping you and you can do something
really dangerous with it and then you
have to think about are there other ways
to stop this again the surveillance can
help even with a bio weapon that we
talked about but also are there ways to
create safeguards around how the
language models themselves work that
could make the situation safer or at
least buy us more time to set up better
defense
could you say more about this particular
example because I think about the sort
of cost asymmetry and offense versus
defense and maybe there isn't
not understanding the specifics
personally maybe um misthinking this but
I think of let's just say Micro Drone
like swarm drone
attacks and if you have a Target let's
just say there's a tank that's the
Target and then you have a hundred
drones released with explosives or a
pack of drones it's relatively
inexpensive to launch that offense but
it could be very very expensive or even
if it's like a a very targeted attack
using bio weapons against an individual
but with some type of distributed attack
the defense seems really tough what are
some of the most promising Avenues of
Defense because I'm sure you have and I
have seen examples of circumventing the
restrictions placed on some of these
large language models
for making something they shouldn't make
or
breaking into a neighbor's house where
there are ways that you can circumvent
it I don't necessarily want to give
people a how-to guide in this
conversations yeah but there's some
clever ways to circumvent what are some
of the most promising avenues for
establishing some defensive capabilities
with these types of things
there's constraints and there there's
defense so if you go and ask open AI uh
chatgpt how do I create a buy weapon and
it will tell you it's not going to help
you and as you said there are ways to
jailbreak this so the first thing you
can do is try and improve those right
cut off these sort of back doors and
there's a lot of research going into
that right now from the big Labs from
academics and I do think we'll get
iteratively better at this over time so
you get sort of an anti-fragility effect
of people are trying to hack these
things and they're figuring out all the
hacks and getting better at it but the
other thing I would point out is when
you have a hosted service like chat GPT
or anthropics Claude you can also just
like know your customer monitor what
they're doing you know have terms and
service you know cut them off law
enforcement can get involved and you
know I think those are just important
conventional measures but notably they
don't apply to the open source models
um so whatever you do to try and prevent
jailbreaks or or try and prevent certain
types of questions from being answered
once you have an open source model those
may as well not exist so it's extremely
easy to kind of remove that that safety
protection so when I think about the
overall AI risk landscape part of what
I'm worried about is just how many
different actors there are in varying
degrees of concern about this and
varying degrees of control you know when
I think about an individual lab like
open AI or anthropic I feel pretty good
I think they're doing responsible things
I think they're doing great Safety
Research but they're not the only ones
out there and so a lot of times when
people talk about
you know how will you improve the safety
of these or how will you solve
alignments which we'll get to as well
I'm sure they think about this kind of
idealized lab that's like doing all the
right things and they're keeping the
untested AI in a safe box and it's you
know not connected to the internet or
not embedded in critical infrastructure
and like that'll be how we iterate into
a safe place and I'm like yeah I believe
you and there are 10 other actors at
least that that are also doing things
yes and there there's a penalty for
doing the safety work costs money and
time and means you're not going to have
the latest greatest most powerful model
on the market and that sort of like game
theoretic Dynamic is more the thing I'm
concerned about and that I think creates
a lot of risk
how do you incentivize the this might
not be the right way to think about it
but sort of the closed system players
the proprietary shops again might not be
the right terminology but how do you
incentivize them to allocate a lot of
resources to safety when you have other
players who may not play by those rules
or open source options which I've seen
in some discords creating things that
you would not believe how do you create
those incentives I think it's a really
hard problem and even if you solve it in
the short run you may just get to a
place where the sort of race Dynamics
kind of take over I think we're really
fortunate in who runs the current big
Labs you know I know Sam Altman very
well Adam D'Angelo who's a board member
of saunas also an open EI board I know
the anthropic team really well I'm
closely involved with them and those
leaders are just True Believers in the
safety issue and they care right it's
like their own lives at stake and their
families lives at stake I think that's a
really powerful force and I think it
served us well so far and I think this
is also true of many of the leaders
inside the other labs that I know I know
less well and I think that's the thing
that we we most have going for us right
now and part of what we've been trying
to do is just convince more of the rest
to care as well and just have as many
people as you can care and then try and
make sure those organizations are a
little better resourced and I don't know
how long that will go on for but it's a
good place right now but there have been
some some new Labs that have been
founded very recently where I'm more
concerned about this and you know in
some cases they claim to care about
safety they've got a certain approach
that sounds good on paper but I don't
know where it will really go but just
trying to get the the labs to
communicate with each other and to
engage with the research and to just
care about the issue in the first place
I think is the best thing we have going
for us
so in addition to bio weapons which at
least as I listen to you describe it
seems to highlight smaller groups or
probably individual players but maybe
not State actors I would imagine as a
layperson that disinformation campaigns
and really sophisticated campaigns run
by state actors will become more and
more of something to contend with but in
your mind what are some of the
additional threats that are potentially
catalyzed or enabled by AI outside of
the bioweapons the other big one we
worry about is is just the alignment
issue
so as you have more and more powerful
systems
you discover that it's harder than you
would think to get them to adhere to
human values we care about the things we
care about and sometimes that's because
we've sort of poorly specified what we
care about if you just step back and
forget Ai and talk to humans about
philosophy and fairness and Equity
there's no sort of consensus answer
right now these are like still
philosophical problems so we can't even
like really well Define them for each
other but we're also trying to instruct
this kind of alien-like human system to
care about and incorporate in some cases
what are like paradoxical goals but also
are very very nuanced and have to do
with with trade-offs whereas what they
naturally want to do is maximize like
achieve a goal as well as possible and
so this idea of instrumental convergence
which is no matter what goal you give a
system if it's trying to maximize it it
eventually gets to a place where it
wants a lot more resources who wants
control and it wants to not be shut off
and that's when you get into concerns
about the thing that is most likely to
shut off the computers is the humans and
so if you have a sufficiently powerful
system that has gathered enough
resources uh it might decide to contain
that threat just as part of achieving
some other goal which maybe we gave it
in the first place or maybe it came up
with on its own and I don't think any of
this story requires Consciousness by the
way people get in a rabbit hole when
they engage in that part but it's just
you know you got to keep in mind this
thing sounds human because it's a
language model and it's it's meant to
sound as human as possible we've asked
it to maximize that goal in itself but
it is not human it is very alien-like
under the surface we don't know how it
works and we can't even get it to do
some simple constraints like not
threaten to kill the end user in a chat
script
um or like not give the recipe for
Napalm if he coax it out in the right
way and later more powerful systems
you're going to need to incorporate more
important uh more nuanced constraints
than that and so there's a bit of a you
know again this sort of offense defense
arms race of like how good will we get
at constraining and aligning the system
compared to how fast will it progress
and by the way this is a place where I
disagree with with David Deutsch he's
very much an accelerationist you know
the once there'll be no constraints on
the AI and I think the Crux of the
argument is speed
um I basically agree with him that our
normal sort of iterative processes can
solve all these problems they are
solvable problems but I don't know that
we'll have enough time usually we have
many decades to solve very hard problems
and the nature of AI development is you
could have very fast take off this is
what part of why Alias are so concerned
literally like maybe next year all of a
sudden there's extremely powerful AI or
even if it's more moderate than that
maybe 10 years from now we have this
extremely powerful AI that isn't
obviously enough time there isn't
obviously enough attention going to the
defense side to align things before we
get there and we also don't know which
actor will produce it maybe it will be
antagonistic state or maybe it'll just
be somebody who who doesn't care about
the safety issues or is trying to
maximize commercialization or something
is like stripped out the things that are
slowing down the system that cause
safety and all that just feels very
chaotic and like a lot of things could
go wrong in unpredictable ways
okay so I would love to ask you just so
people don't curl up in the fetal
position under their desk after this
as a very close friend of mine said he
almost did after listening to a separate
episode that I did with Eric Schmidt my
second conversation with him where we
talked a lot about AI could you make the
optimistic case or give us some of the
upside and paint a picture of what
things might look like
in I know this is very hard to do and
impossible to do accurately unless
you're
uh
you know some type of of soothsayer and
can peer into your Crystal Ball but what
might the future look like in three five
ten years if we're able to manifest some
of the promise of AI
on the positive side oh man this is so
fun
this is the part I like to talk about
because there's so many like good things
I recently published a piece in in
Fortune actually that's kind of looking
at this through the the work lens
because I think that even a lot of the
things we've talked about so far in the
episode I think can be really Amplified
with AI so for example we're talking
about how people's schedules get chopped
up and part of this is just we have
these very coarse ways of trying to you
know solve the multi-faceted problem of
like there are five people with you know
different work streams and schedules and
you want to get them together while
disrupting the focus blocks as little as
possible and really we do this just by
kind of like looking at everyone's
calendar and like looking for the open
slots between them and sometimes you'll
move one meeting to make an extra space
and oh look often no meeting Wednesday
is often clear on everybody's calendars
let's use that and you end up chopping
up everyone's calendar but an AI can do
that really well and give you you know
ideally sort of do like a
defragmentation on everyone's calendar
and just keep iterating until it's as
perfect as possible honoring as many
people's preferences as possible can
also eliminate the need for meetings in
many cases you know one of the things
we're excited about in Asana is sort of
identifying more proactively when you
even need to call a meeting when you
have a decision that needs to be made
when there's a conflict and in lieu of
having intelligence around that you just
do course things like we're going to get
together every week and share status
updates and kind of resync and see what
decisions are coming up now and I think
that you know having AI serve more as
sort of like air traffic control looking
at the the work overall in the
organization can just lead to not only
Better Business outcomes but much better
sort of individual subjective
experiences of how your work happens and
you know that's sort of just the tip of
the iceberg on work and then you know I
think the thing that people talk about a
lot is sort of you know automating a lot
of work that is road to repetitive or uh
and just that also coincides with the
work that humans don't want to do
um there's a lot of knowledge work that
looks like that there's also a lot of
physical work that can be automated with
robotics uh and I think every time
that's happened we just get a little
closer to the the Jetson style world
where you know you're living your best
life and spending as little time as
possible in the stuff that you don't
want to do and additionally I think
there's this uh
this thing that's a little less explored
of having just like a really great
um you know coach and cheerleader both
on an individual basis and for the team
like imagine you have like the world's
greatest project manager
um that's integrated into every team and
it knows all the best practices from
everything and it knows the context of
the specific project you're working on
um and that means you can kind of let go
of a lot of things that cause continual
partial attention disorder of like did
we really get to a concrete Next Step
here you just said partial attention
disorder right yeah yeah continual
statism that is amazing that is such a
great a great phrase okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna write that down oh yeah it's a
it's a David Allen thing from uh getting
things done David Allen yeah okay yeah I
didn't I didn't realize I was an acronym
from that okay got it yeah continual
partial attention deficit I could assume
yeah well in general I mean this is part
of the reason we built Asana is like
people carry around their task lists and
their heads or it's in their email inbox
and they're rescanning their email inbox
all the time and if you can get it into
a system that you trust to show you
those things at the right time or send
you reminders at the right time you can
let go of it in the active memory and
get more space for presence uh and I
think AI can be doing this
um at a much higher level of abstraction
for entire teams and entire companies so
you don't have to worry about you know
is there a dependency that's going to
affect the critical path on this project
we're working on that's going to
eventually mean that a deadline slips
like right now that's a lot of what
managers are doing is looking for these
problems but I think an AI can be can be
doing it for you doing a lot more
effectively helping Focus the managers
on where they'll be most useful this is
the actual blocking dependency that you
you need to fix you need to Resource
better you need to scope down you need
to do something to change this and it
can even be doing softer stuff like hey
marketing and sales are fighting we can
tell just by like looking at the text
analysis of the conversations they're
having
um and uh you know I think that can just
like go so much further and get rid of a
lot of this work about work that that we
we do a lot of manual processes to try
and like work around these problems and
you know have the systems in place that
that we can catch things some of the
time
um I think all that can go away so that
people can focus much more on the
creative productive work that really you
know drives the business forward towards
its goals
yeah my team and I use Asana we have for
years we also use more recently chat GPT
and I'm sure we'll experiment with more
language models but it is remarkable
I'll tell you what's in the hopper for
my follow-up questions so it can gestate
with you for a minute but the AI
Integrations into Asana that you are
most excited about and part of the
reason I ask is right now
we use a number of different tools but
to really focus on Asana we're using it
not just for tracking the work of other
people but tracking our own work so
trying to take these open loops and put
them into a repository such that we can
see what is kind of green yellow red and
at a glance
keep track of all these things
especially I mean I shouldn't say
especially but on a small team the
problems that are created if you don't
do that it's true for a large team as
well but a lot of people are
self-directed everyone is self-directed
largely and everyone is a direct report
of mine effectively so it's it's it's
it's proven to be a critical piece of
our infrastructure and process on the
chat TPT side you know I'm just
imagining how these things are going to
be integrated in the future and there
are already these Integrations with chat
GPT and I'm imagining when it gets to
sort of the WeChat
point where you can say I want to make
roast pork tonight with these parameters
this is what I like this is what I don't
like
have all of the ingredients delivered to
me within the next three hours and
a b and c right turn on my oven preheat
it or whatever I mean it's gonna happen
quickly and I mean there's the downside
to that with the Napalm example too but
the Integrations are really interesting
to me and I'm wondering what you're most
excited about with respect to AI
Integrations into Asana
you know I think I've been talking about
some of the longer term versions of like
we we almost sort of conceptualize it as
AI is an extension of your team and I
think a lot of what we've seen in
products today is you know the sort of
co-pilot mentality of like there's one
person trying to accomplish a specific
thing you know make a dinner tonight and
it's helping fill in some of the steps
or you know explode small details into a
complete plan we will definitely do that
kind of stuff you know we've already
launched in beta like a writing
assistant to help you draft tasks you
know we can take a task and break it
into subtasks we've written the sort of
summarization tools that I think are
very powerful like you come back to a
thread and 50 people have kind of gone
back and forth in comments and be really
great if something just sort of said
what were the key points who was doing
most of the speaking kind of catch you
up really quickly that stuff will be
really great but the things that I think
are going to be really powerful are
about I like to frame this is sort of
like push versus pull AI so what we've
got now is Paul like the user is always
deciding this is when I'm going to use
the writing assistance this is what I'm
going to use the summarization tool
first push would be more like what you
already see with like news feeds today
where it's like the intelligence is
decided this is important for you to see
and it's like putting it in a queue or
sending you an email and then you know
these ideas like helping to identify the
open Loops in the first place so
something that happens in in meetings
and common threads is people will
identify a decision and they'll sort of
like give some thoughts about it but
they won't necessarily like decide it
and I think it would be really powerful
if you just did the language analysis of
like hey actually this is still
undecided and maybe even like assign it
to somebody to follow it through to
completion or you said these three
things needed to be done but you didn't
actually assign them to anybody and so
like that would be so that would be so
helpful I'm gonna I'm gonna admit it's
it's embarrassing but you know some of
these things are very aspirational for
me still it's it's not a perfectly oiled
machine yeah exactly this would be
incredibly helpful just to identify AI
what got lost in the shuffle like during
the offsite you guys captured a million
different things and you prioritize them
or made an attempt to but for whatever
reason you forgot four out of the you
know 12 top items and dropping that into
a system with some visibility with would
be super super helpful yeah we'd love to
take that responsibility off the user's
hands
um so they they can relax into to doing
the work but feel like Asana itself is
this super diligent project and goal
manager and even do sort of longer Arc
things like often you'll be in a kickoff
meeting and you'll identify key risks to
a project and the idea for this is that
somebody will remember those key risks
and kind of like come back to them and
notice when they're manifesting but in
reality you know you may or you may not
do that you may forget about them but
the system ideally could remember them
and say oh hey here's that thing
happening that you talked about at the
beginning there's a production delay or
the guest is not available
it's a podcast but um and sort of like
just be always watching for you as well
as helping you celebrate accomplishments
and recognize people for for doing great
work you have to not do that in a creepy
way but I think that there is a way to
have it feel really really positive and
and feel like it's truly helping you see
more you don't have to like go through
every single task everyone on your team
is doing to see when they do something
really great there are so many examples
I can think of of where push AI would be
helpful assuming that it doesn't create
an information Deluge or a paradox of
choice issue right for people who are
maybe confronted with options that they
weren't prepared to
select from but I'll give you an example
recently I like to organize trips with
my very close friends and get them on
the calendar well in advance because
everybody's busy if you don't do it it's
just not going to happen and I'm
considering a fishing trip like a river
trip with friends
and all of my full-time employees right
now are experimenting with chat GPT for
basically rough drafting different tasks
and for something like that
you could very easily imagine a world in
which that's an Asana and it's a bit of
a clumsy large task so it's not quite
the what is the next the next physical
action you know Allah David Allen but if
you had you know to draft an itinerary
for
a fishing trip
in a mountainous region blah blah blah
blah blah parameter parameter and then
it could very easily as chatgp did draft
a pretty compelling rough draft it's not
going to be the final version but it
provides you with enough
to save a lot of time on miscellaneous
searches and calling through sponsored
versus organic versus this versus that
content varm versus you know individual
author blog that has some higher page
rank or whatever it just saves so much
time on the front end it could very
easily see that auto populating somehow
in an Asana task absolutely or even
whole projects so you know right now we
live in this world where you either get
the building blocks of Asana and you
fill it in all yourself or you use a
very abstract template like you know I
want to run a marketing campaign but but
as you said you can be very specific
like not not only I'm gonna do a fishing
trip in Montana but like this exact City
and like you know have it fill in all
the tasks and like tell you what like
the local stores are and like how you're
going to get there and it can really
bridge this gap between you know nothing
in template to giving you customized you
know bespoke projects in as much detail
as you give it at the outset it will
engage with all that detail and do a
great job that'll really help people a
lot in particular with you know one of
the complaints we get about Asana a lot
is just like I don't know if I'm using
it well I don't know if I'm like using
everything I should be or organizing
this the right way and and having that
that sort of assistant that is an expert
on Asana and an expert kind of on
everything in the world can really help
give you the confidence that you know
you're using all the building blocks in
the right way and then you kind of take
it from there I want to if you don't
mind zoom out to maybe some of the
philosophical
level and ask you a question that ties
together the energy management we were
talking about earlier with time blocking
and ensuring that you do things that
nourish
you nourish your soul however you want
to think about it like this trip that
I'm considering taking with friends and
the reason I ask is that
for at least a hundred years maybe
longer many writers have postulated that
with a b and c technological advances
we're going to reach a level of such
efficiency and Effectiveness that the
real question will be how the modern
worker takes advantage of this vast
amount of leisure time but somehow
humans being humans we've managed
alongside that generally to I don't want
to say squatter but you find ways to
Fritter away time
often using many sort of parallel
technological advances I think the net
net that I perceive in my audience at
least is that we have the tools to be
more efficient than ever but a lot of
people still feel a sense of time
scarcity and I'm wondering what you do
personally or how you think about that
type of time blogging making sure the
big things or the items that really
nourish you
find time in your schedule maybe that's
a lazy question but I know it's one that
comes up directly indirectly a lot for
people in my periphery so I'd be curious
to hear anything that you might have to
say about that first of all I just say
I'm a work in progress on that so it's
something I yeah you know I'm always
trying to get better at uh and you know
over time I've just learned there are
some things that are sacrosanct for me
and they get fixed in my calendar and
you know things happen they won't
necessarily happen every week but if
maybe two weeks ago in a row then I'll
find a new block for it make sure it
happens this includes you know of course
sleep exercise you know spending time
with my wife you know we do a date night
every Saturday but sometimes we're on a
trip or we do something with friends on
Saturday and so we'll find a different
different night of the week for that and
just try and be mindful and intentional
about it rather than just I think maybe
10 years ago would be more like well
I've got all these things I'm doing and
if I feel all done enough by a certain
hour then I'll go work out and of course
like then you further away your time and
like you never get to it and so I've
become a lot more regular and scheduled
and I think that serves me well and
there are longer Arc versions of this
like I try and go for a solo hike once
every three months you know my wife and
I have certain vacations we try and do
some of them are Traditions with friends
some of them are just us when you say
solo hike is that like an afternoon
stroll are we talking about a long
vacation you said every three months
what is what is a solo trip like that
look like I mean I live in the Bay Area
which is just phenomenal for hiking so
usually it's a day trip it is incredible
yeah it's incredible but you know like
uh you know I'll do like a 10 mile hike
or something and in a day I love the
mountain area for example and just I
find that very restorative and I'll tell
people about it after and they'll say oh
you should have invited me I live in
that area I love going on Hikes I'm like
no no you don't don't understand that's
not how it works
um
and I I've just tried to be reflective
on what those things are and at what
Cadence I I need them and you know what
works for me and what doesn't and what's
taxing and what's restorative and just
try and ever iterate towards towards
better balance over time if I may pull
us back to your book list which I I do
not believe is publicly available but
maybe we can share some of them to the
extent that you're comfortable
I'm wondering what of these books you've
Revisited in times of uncertainty or
duress or stuckness you have a lot of
great books and they're categorized in
in all sorts of different ways you have
psychology mindfulness you have
leadership and strategy epistemology and
philosophy are there any books that
you've returned to when you're like you
know what I just need
I feel like I need a refresher or a
reminder in maybe high stress or high
stakes periods of your life if that's if
that question makes any sense at all I'm
a little bit of a type a person with
this where I'm usually going for a new
book but uh I guess the way I think of
it more is like a lot of the books are
very similar to each other
and so I think of it more as I'd like to
read a book about mindfulness
you know every six months or something
like that and they're they're authors
like Jack cornfield's extremely prolific
he has many books I have I have one in
here that you know touch me in a
personal way but like there are many
that are quite good which one of his
books the one I have in here is the lamp
in the darkness you know it's
particularly useful when going through
grief you know he has just a lot of
great books on on day-to-day living and
so I think I'm more likely to sort of
look for which one haven't I read yet
that you know a lot of it will overlap
and he'll sell them some of the same
stories anyway but it'll just be like a
different angle on it and so you know
it's usually I'm sort of cycling through
like mindfulness and like leadership
those books you know business books all
rhyme with each other as well and then
sort of more intellectual stuff like
beginning of infinity
if you had to re-read a biography that
you have read
let's just say you know in the next few
months you had to sit down with
something you've already read or a
person for whom you've already read one
biography you could read a new biography
of them I'll allow that
who might you choose or what book might
you choose
I think if I was going to reread a
biography it would be Churchill and
there's there's a few different ones but
uh Walking With Destiny happens to be
the one I read and his life is just
extraordinary and it feels like fiction
to go through hits and in terms of
biographers I you know I think chernow
and uh and Cara are A Cut Above and so
anybody they're writing about I will
become interested in
yeah their dedication to the craft is
just unbelievable if it's okay with you
Dustin El toaska a few more questions
and then we can we can land the we can
land the plane uh and if if these are
dead ends I will take the blame but I'll
ask just a few of my
common questions because I like to ask
them that's why they're common so one is
the Billboard question and that is if
you could put a quote a phrase word an
image anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get something
in front of many many many many people
what might you put on that billboard I
don't know if I have a pithy phrase for
this but oh no I do actually the title
of my media posts is uh you know Live
Well to work hard I think people create
this false dichotomy of work-life
balance where they think of it only in
terms of like the number of hours you
have for work and what's left for for
life and don't really think about the
quality of those hours and I just like
over time just it's come up a lot in
this conversation but just more and more
on appreciation for I have to rest
really well to be able to do my job well
and perform well during the hours that
I'm working but also all these other
parts of life you know don't exercise
yoga using the back putty spending you
know spending time with my wife and
family and friends it's still all part
of of me and you know part of being a
whole person uh and I think particularly
in the tech industry particularly in
your 20s people think of it more as like
yeah I'm gonna work hard right now and
like later I'll live my life and later
it doesn't come unless you're
intentional about it and I think you'll
be more effective than just the
sprinting Live Well to work hard I'll
link to the medium piece in the show
notes as well and one more book question
because I love books as you can pick up
if I were to scan this camera around the
room you'd be horrified by the number of
stacks of books that I have here
but I tend to accumulate there's this
term sundoku which is like a Japanese
term for accumulating stacks of books
that you have not read that's that's
very much highlighted in the room that
I'm in right now but what book or books
have you gifted
often to other people if you've gifted
any books
could be recommended yeah I'm an audible
guy so I like never give a physical book
to people something that's come up a lot
lately is this book the road back to you
which is about the Enneagram
and I'll just say up front it's like
written by a former preacher and he's
got some like religious tones and that
that doesn't really appeal to me but I I
just found the descriptions of the
Enneagram types to be just really spot
on especially the one of my type type
five
um and just really felt like reading my
diary and
um yeah you know I've recommended it to
a few other people who had similar
experiences and I had read a bunch of
about Enneagram before and it was like
ah this sort of fits it sort of doesn't
and then this one really spoke to me
I'll check it out yeah the the conscious
leadership folks use Enneagram a lot I
don't want to speak for all of them but
at least Jim and Diana do and I know
that I believe when Toby of Shopify and
I last spoke on the podcast He also
mentioned I think they may type everyone
in the company who works at the company
do you guys do that at Asana or is that
more opt-in for you and a handful of
folks who may be interested or is that
systematized throughout the company in
any way I think it depends on the team
I've done it for my directs we've
actually done it for the board as well
because it's often useful to kind of
understand yeah the interactions between
two types but I don't know how far in
the company it provides a lot quite a
lot of people do know their type though
yeah for people who want to explore that
check it out does the road back to you
is that a suitable starting place for
people who have no familiarity with the
Enneagram oh yeah absolutely yeah great
okay perfect so I will link to that as
well can I give one more recommendation
oh please absolutely this one hasn't
come up in a while but it was talked
about a lot when it's first published
but uh Scout mindset it's booked by by
Julia gallif and she's a rationalist and
she's near the effect of altruism
community and I think it's just like a
good way of getting into that way of
thinking and I think it's very related
to conscious leadership a lot of it is
about kind of challenging your stories
and just like being open and curious and
how you think about ideas and learn
about the world and something I've come
back to a lot perfect well Dustin we
have covered a lot of ground and I I'm
sure I could go for hours and hours more
with all of the many notes that I still
have around me but is there anything
before you want to a close that you'd
like to mention closing comments
requests of the audience anything at all
that you'd like to add
I think we got it all out I'll probably
as soon as soon as I hang up I'm sure
I'll come up with something but we could
do a voice addendum yes a PS from Dustin
if need be but uh it's nice to see you
and thanks for making the time today I
really appreciate I have lots of things
I'm going to follow up on I am going to
get the road back to you because I've
been meaning to reboot the Enneagram for
myself I've had everyone in my company
typed I do find it helpful even if not
necessarily an interaction but even so
that each person can be perhaps more
aware
myself included of strengths and
weaknesses and how your predispositions
can show up as handicaps that you may
not recognize off the bat find it very
helpful so I'll revisit that can you say
what your uh type is you've been typed
yeah I can I am a self-preservation sex
and that'll make a lot of sense to
people if they read the description
they'll be like oh yeah shocker not
surprised and it's also fun it is a fun
exercise and I have found at least
practical in more ways than than one
might expect there are some people who
develop or have severe allergies to the
Enneagram one of my very close friends
is one of them so it's not for everybody
everybody but it's one of the tools one
of the many modalities that can be
helpful and I really appreciate you
being so open and willing to dig into a
lot of the specifics and cover so much
ground I feel like we got got a lot into
one conversation so thank you Dustin
yeah thank you I'd highly recommend the
experience and yeah and for people
actually you know what one last question
I keep giving these like second goodbyes
and third goodbyes but is there anything
that you would
like to see me discuss more on the
podcast or whether that's topics to
explore particular people does anything
come to mind that you think could be
fruitful to explore on the podcast
well you know I'll just say I was very
delighted that the last episode I heard
was was Jack cornfield and you know I
thought that was one of the best that
I've heard over the years and I know
he's been on more than once but yeah I
feel like you could go a long time on on
sort of the mindfulness and the
self-care and you know you do so it's
it's not something you're not doing
already but I think that's usually my
favorite kind of content great yeah
thanks it's I think of that personally
as I think it was uh Kim who first used
this phrasing with me but like put your
own oxygen mask on before helping others
like just that the importance of
self-care if you actually want to do a
lot in the world uh so I will it's a
good reminder for me and I will I'll be
sure to have Jack back on he's a Presa
perennial favorite and to everybody
listening we talked about a lot we made
many references we talked about books
people different principles and so on
including the template for time tracking
that you mentioned which we will put
into the show notes as per usual for
everyone to peruse at tim.blog podcast
and in closing I'll just say to
everybody out there back buddy don't
miss it and should have been my
billboard yeah exactly back buddy and be
just a little bit Kinder than is
necessary to others and to yourself and
until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify as thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been and spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus the 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
this episode is brought to you by Roka
makers of the world's most versatile
eyewear I am incredibly impressed with
Roka actually the quality is outstanding
and a lot of my friends who are Elite
athletes also wear them that's how I was
introduced to them I like to stay active
a lot of long term listeners will know
this and my eyewear has to be up to the
task brands that make everyday eyewear
sunglasses and glasses don't generally
build them for people who are really on
the move a lot so you have to wear
clunky shades on a run deal with glasses
that slip off your face or buy some kind
of sport specific frames Roka has fixed
all that by packing the same features
used in eyewear for Olympic gold
medalists and world champions into
stylish everyday sunglasses eyeglasses
and reading glasses so you get more with
less it's an elegant solution with Rocco
one pair does it all you can go from
work to a workout to dinner with friends
without ever needing to switch glasses I
never have to interrupt hike for
instance to take my sunglasses is often
wipe my nose or frames because roca's
no-slip feature keeps my shades right
where they started if you wear
prescription glasses which I will
probably end up wearing pretty soon as
you get older you know these things
happen you can finally ditch the
contacts and have no slip fashionable
frames that keep up with you and your
active lifestyle personally I've been
using their Rory blue light glasses
after Sunset and I can feel the
Improvement in my sleeve quality I'm
falling asleep faster during the day
I've been loving the Falcon this is
roka's ultra lightweight titanium
aviators been wearing those say when I
go out on nice sunny days in Austin for
long walks I also enjoy supporting Roca
speaking of Austin as Hometown Heroes is
they are based in my backyard right here
in Austin Texas roca's Ultra lightweight
no slip fit and advanced lens Coatings
combined with their exceptional style I
actually have many other styles I just
mentioned too also make these a favorite
for a lot of my friends you may have
heard about about them from Andrew
huberman and many others there are a lot
of people wearing these things the
quality as I mentioned before is really
outstanding they are very very durable
and with more than 19
000 five-star reviews
wait until they get to twenty thousand
that'll be a celebration I bet but with
more than 19 000 five-star reviews Roka
has created a solution that active
people love plus they hand build their
glasses sunglasses and reading glasses
all in the USA check out my favorite
frames and get 20 off of your first
order using Code Tim 20 that's Tim two
zero at roca.com that's code tim20 at
roca.com r-o-k-a.com
[Applause]